explains it that he knows that it's a
risky move to do this but he's bold
enough to try it music industry is just
not used to queer artists if there was a
big risk you took with this album what
would you say it was I'd say the biggest
risk on this album was the element of
sex the music industry isn't ready for
queer artists he says which is a bit
like claiming that zumba isn't ready for
middle-aged white women he also says
that the biggest risk he's taking is
being sexual I mean that's a pretty big
risk we have to admit I mean it takes a
lot of guts to do the same thing that
literally every other person in your
profession is doing has already done and
has been doing for decades now there's a
risk I mean that's boldness if I ever
saw it next he's going to tell me that
he that he went out on a limb and picked
the Chiefs to go to the Super Bowl this
year